and i i i don't mind saying that cody ko
is a [ __ ] hot dude hot dude
i think you're highly attractive even
with the little
haircut no matter what you have two
earrings not even a mullet it's just one
earring it's just like a legitimately
like eight-year-old girl haircut
i think you're legit hot dude i used to
have a joke in my stand up he's like i
used to have a crush on you
i used to have a joke in my stand up i
would be i'd be like man what a great
crowd dude like uh
this is like a hot dude right here
and then um
i'd say like you know like that's me man
i'm perfectly comfortable
saying when a dude is hot you know yeah
oh yeah like uh
like most guys if you ask him is this
guy hot they'd be like dude would you
think i'm some kind of goo dude yeah i'm
not gay man right but they know exactly
when to be jealous of a hot dude talking
to their girls sure so clearly every guy
knows when another guy's hot oh yeah you
know a hot dude when you see one oh yeah
and i'm down with admitting that i'm
down with calling it out you're saying
you know like you're not welcome to talk
to my girl
you know
like right here you're not welcome to
talk to my girl you're not
you're good
yeah then that's the job
yeah i mean you'd be disturbed if like
lux came home and she was like dude i
have a friend from work that wants to
hang out his name's cody he looked at
his instagram you're like
not [ __ ] cool dude no but yeah you do
appreciate a good looking man i did more
than most you you you're more than you
call it out yeah did i call you the
gorgeous pop risky on this i don't know
on this episode if you did probably you
were distracted by cody's eyes
right i like to surround myself with a
hot dude so this has been a very
enjoyable hour but you told me i was
good looking the day i met you oh good
do you remember i met you at raycon i
don't know if you even remember vidcon
like yooka brought me over to you to
like meet you he's like yeah this is
paul by the way and you're like hey
good looking dude
it's like the first thing you said
you're hot as [ __ ] by the way yeah i say
that regularly but only when it's a hot
dude right yeah i shoot some straight
shooter yeah it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude